you can get the two biggest scandals of
our time wrong in the media
you can say spygate was a hoax it wasn't
and collusion was real
it wasn't and you get a pulitzer prize
if you regularly listen to conservative
podcasts like you are right now you
almost certainly know of dan bongino's
the dan bongino show
bongino formerly a new york city cop and
white house secret service agent
now hosts a successful daily show
breaking down the news of the day and
taking listeners
places the mainstream media will not go
one of his top focuses the last few
years
has been the deep state war against
president trump through its countless
attempts to produce a scandal and
corruption around the presidency
along with frequent coverage in the show
has published three books on the subject
the latest is follow the money the
shocking deep state connections of the
anti-trump cabal
which was just released this week one of
the biggest scandals from
as dan puts it swampy dc elite and
wealthy democrats is spygate
that's a buzzword we've all heard a lot
and it can be a difficult story to
unpack but dan makes it simple
in this episode you'll hear him discuss
with me this and other attempts to
dismantle president trump and his
administration
we'll also discuss the defund the police
movement from dan's perspective
as an officer in new york city when
those streets were cleaned up
and the difference is between serving as
a secret service agent in the clinton
bush and obama administrations
hey hey and welcome this is the ben
shapiro show sunday special this week
featuring a very special guest dan
bongino
just a reminder we'll be doing some
bonus questions at the end with dan the
only way to get access to that part of
the conversation is to go become a
member head on over to dailywire.com
become a member you'll have access to
all the full conversations with every
one of our awesome guests dan
thanks so much for stopping by you know
what a pleasure it's been so long i'm
always looking uh
at you at the top of the charts i i i we
see you and i look down there and i'm
like oh he's coming he's coming for me
now you have a great show it's great to
finally see we've always kind of crossed
paths but
this should be an interesting
conversation absolutely so let's jump
right in
to the the trump issues so a lot of
folks in the media i think kind of get
you wrong as just the trump guy because
you've obviously been very pro president
trump during his tenure but
it took you a while to get there you
weren't originally a trump guy so
tell me about sort of the evolution from
where you were on trump to where you are
on trump now yeah it's fascinating i'd
endorse ted cruz and i
remember calling around at the time to
people trying to get
get them on board law enforcement people
and other folks with prominent public
profile saying hey
you know ted's our guy tonight i still
like ted cruz a lot obviously
and i made one specific call to someone
let's say in the industry who
you know but shall remain nameless for
the purpose of this interview and um she
said to me
i'm all about trump and i was stunned
because this is a die-hard conservative
and i said really i said i i don't know
i don't see it you know the democrat
history and all that other stuff
she said listen to me she said this guy
gets it he understands
she said i i think the word was he can
be transactional at times
but she made a great point to me she
said you know do you want a showman
and a guy who plays conservative and has
all these people convinced and gets in
there and doesn't do anything
conservative
or a guy who gets it that conservatives
were his way to the white house
um and understands that conservatism is
actually a path forward
maybe it wasn't in his heart the entire
time but he's actually going to do
conservative stuff
and i said you know let me check this
guy out and obviously after he went
uh you know and won the primary you know
i was all in i mean the options there
were
president trump or hillary clinton and
as the presidency wore on
i think the real deal sealer for me was
the spygate scandal which
i just felt like why did they see this
guy as such a threat
i mean it really i think was the biggest
scandal of our time that really sold me
on that this guy
is an existential threat to everything i
found wrong with the
proverbial swamp there so let's talk
about spike because you were on that
super early so you you were the the
main maybe progenitor of a lot of the
information that was coming out
and i'll be honest with you i was kind
of following it tangentially because i
figured okay the information is going to
come out a certain point i don't know
what i don't know
i'm willing to kind of see where this
leads and you know i
i have a certain baseline faith in law
enforcement they weren't going to do
what they obviously did
but you you never really had that sort
of uh that sort of faith in the system
that they weren't going to do what they
apparently did so
what led you originally to think okay
this is
like an actual scandal maybe for folks
who don't understand you can actually
walk people through
what spygate constitutes because it
becomes sort of just this meme or slogan
the left throws out there whenever they
wish to dismis dismiss something sort of
like the
benghazi across deck so what exactly is
spygate and why should americans care
i'm glad you started the question that
way because my wife's in the studio with
me here but
you know i like your show i enjoy your
content i couldn't believe
early on you you were a skeptic and
i was a skeptic too i was a spygate
skeptic i know that sounds weird because
it you know it doesn't seem like you
jumped right but i didn't
i haven't been a former secret service
agent i thought the whole case was bs2
i said to myself there's no way this
could have happened there were
guardrails set up for this kind of stuff
i said this could not i had the same
skepticism you did
we were in a hotel my wife and i in
dallas for we're doing another
job out there and i get a call from a
source
he had tried to contact me multiple
times and honestly i thought he was just
being hyperbolic
and he had insisted to me dan you don't
understand
the president of the united states and
his campaign were spied on
by insiders at the fbi who had
no legal basis whatsoever to do it the
story sounded so ridiculous but i
figured let me just take his call
finally
i spent about a half an hour on the
phone he walks me through everything and
the essence of it is very simple
you know you can get lost in the wonky
but it's really no more difficult than
this
they had a political beef with the
soon-to-be president united states at
the time candidate trump
they had no legal mechanism in the
united states to spy on him
so they fabricated it using a bunch of
freelancers and former intel people
who just made up stories which then
hijacked the justice department into
getting a fisa warrant they spied on him
the story's no more complicated than
that
um now there's other foreign aspects to
it and how they did it and
the walkery of it's quite interesting
but um i would like you i was a skeptic
too i know you
you know you're a patriot like me you
want to believe come on it's not a third
world republic of the united states
but the guy was so convincing on the
phone and as i dug in with more sources
as this guy's telling me the truth and
that's if you go back and read the
original book i wrote on at spygate
which i wrote
three and a half years ago read it
everything's in there ukraine what
happened and i mean it's nothing new
it could have been written yesterday and
that was all most of it was from that
original source what was amazing about
it is that
as as you say like i was kind of slow on
the uptake here because i was just
throughout thinking this can't be real
and at the very least
that maybe this was you know predicated
on
legitimate suspicion and then it just
got to be confirmation bias that at a
certain point
it got to be well it's got to be true
because i believe it has to be true and
therefore if i stretch the rules here if
i stretch the rules there eventually it
will be found to be true
do you think that it was predicated on
the basis that people actually knew
nothing was going on and that they went
forward with it anyway or
was it that they saw kind of some smoke
uh they saw carter page should there
have been suspicions about prior there's
a fish warrant against him in 2014
and they saw george papadopoulos and
they had suspicions about him and they
sort of whipped themselves into a frenzy
to the point where they were willing to
at the very least bend the rules
in order to go after people who are
tangentially associated with the trump
campaign
i think it's all of that um how did it
start well it started for
just pure political interest they needed
an october a november surprise in the
2016 election
and they remember they'd already tried
this on mccain matter of fact my second
book on the topic exonerated have a
whole
uh chapter on this how this the russians
are behind this campaign
is not new they had tried it against
mccain now most people don't remember
that and i always say to people
the reason you don't remember that is
because who was in office when mccain
was running and the answer is george w
bush so he didn't let the cia and fbi
get hijacked into this whole ridiculous
spygate
uh scandal it stopped but if you go back
and look at the articles about mccain if
you google mccain
russians you'll see it's the exact same
people saying john mccain
he's corrupted look he's got these
lobbyists and they work with russians
they tried it one nowhere
so the story's out there they have the
template the and then you have you mix
that
so you have the story there okay part
number two is you have very
entrepreneurial people looking to make
money fusion gps and glenn simpson
glenn simpson has this pre-packaged
russian narrative
there is a 2007 a 2017 2007 wall street
journal article
called uh soviets try to woo washington
or something like that by glenn simpson
and his wife now mary jacoby
you read that 2007 article glenn simpson
of course has fusion gps
hired by hillary clinton later on it
reads like the dossier
it's the exact same players manafort
they're all in that same article so now
you have a political campaign looking
for disinformation
a template that's been tried before hey
let's blame it on the russians like we
did with mccain
you have an obama administration
perfectly willing to play along
you have a former reporter simpson who's
already got the players lined up
manafort's in that 2007 article manafort
gets hired by the trump team and you
have this witch's brew
this perfect storm where they say hey if
we can
slap this fake information because
simpson can't pitch it
because he's a former reporter he's
being paid by hillary the fbi is not
going to believe that
they needed a patina they needed a face
and someone said i've got a bright idea
here
we got this former russia desk guy at
mi6 christopher steele
perfect let's say he said it steele
didn't say any of that
this steel dossier is a fabrication it's
the steel halper simpson dossier
they slapped it on him and all of a
sudden you had a made to order
scandal right there so when you ask like
what was the motivation the answer is
they were
some were mercenary some it was money
some it was political
but it all came to this kind of tip of
the spear
that arrow of spy gate and really just
like i said a witch's brew of disasters
it all happened at the same time so in a
second i want to ask you about the
motivations of the people who are inside
the government because it makes sense
when you're talking about you know
motivated political actors outside the
government who want to win an election
sure but the the
hijacking of the governmental you know
auspices is really the the big scandal
here and i want to ask you about that in
just one second first
let's be real about this you got a lot
of information online and lots of people
would love to have that information
particularly
if they are politically motivated and
that doesn't just mean hackers that
means also
members of the silicon valley cadre if
you can't trust certain elements in
silicon valley to treat conservatives
fairly how can you trust them to handle
your privacy and personal online data
that's why i recommend using expressvpn
every time you go online
big tech companies they can use your ip
address to match your internet activity
to your identity or location
when i use expressvpn search engines and
media sites can't see my ip address at
all
my identity is masked and anonymized
expressvpn has the added benefit of
encrypting 100 of your data to keep you
safe from people who don't want having
that data in the first place
expressvpn software it takes just a
minute to set up on your computer or
phone you tap one button
you are now protected so if you're like
me and you believe that your internet
data belongs to you and not to giant
tech companies who may not like
conservatives very much
expressvpn is the answer protect your
online activity today with the vpn i
personally trust to keep my data safe
visit expressvpn.com ben to claim an
exclusive offer for my fans that's
expressvpn.com for three months free
with a one-year package visit
expressvpn.com ben to get started
let's talk about the government being
hijacked to this particular
cause so obviously you see politically
motivated players the peter strzok's and
the lisa pages
yeah uh and and you see james comey who
just looks like a radical incompetent
throughout this entire process
how many of those people knew that this
was all empty and how many of these
people
were just convinced that because again
there was some smoke i mean to pretend
that there was no smoke is
is i think kind of silly i mean manafort
is
obviously a character with some some
shady ties yeah and i've never defended
him in my book yeah you know
i'm not only i'm talking about metaphor
too let's not pretend like these he was
all on the up and up here either because
then we look like buffoons right
exactly the only big revelation that
really came forth through the entire
revolut
through the entire investigation was the
was the trump tower meeting in june
uh where it appeared that donald trump
jr was willing to hear sort of overtures
from people who are connected to the
russian government about dirt they might
have on hillary which
again is not actually illegal i mean
information coming in and listening to
information is not in fact illegal it
may be
frowned upon but it's not illegal but
you know let's say that you're a member
of the fbi or the cia and you have this
information funnel too do they know from
the outset that it was all or
was it yes
a hundred percent so you have these guys
right who are running this
one the fbi story that it started july
31st of 2016 is total garbage and that
we can just throw that out right now
the fbi gets the dossier information in
the new york field office way before
july 31st 2016. we know that lisa page
has already admitted to that
on the record so have others so they get
this dossier information the dossier is
a total complete fabrication
now the fbi has this woods file where
you know as a lawyer that you know
you're not
you don't ask a question in court you
don't know the answer to right they
asked questions they didn't know the
answer to and they never bothered to
verify the answers afterwards
so you have this woods file and things
that came up like hey listen um
he was in russia with these prostitutes
the famous you know peepee hoax as i
call it
the story was so outrageous that you
would think they'd you know
go to the hotel try to find tapes or
something it was so ridiculous they made
no effort so they knew from the start
that
i'll i'll even be nice to them which
they weren't to us of course even peter
stroke today on twitter is like taking
shots at everyone which is bizarre
you think he'd kind of like slither away
but even being nice say you thought
there was a scintilla
of credibility to this right within
a week or two you could have figured out
the story was entirely bs
i mean we had the michael cohen going a
prague story totally made
up now again even giving them a pass say
through the summer of 2016
they're trying to verify they weren't
but say they were i'm trying to be
generous here
they're absolutely no later than january
of 2017. they know this case to be a
total fabrication
because steele who's attributed all the
information in these phony dossiers
to a guy named uh uh shiddanchenko
his primary source the fbi interviews
denchenko in january of 2017
danchenko says i didn't say that he says
i didn't say that number one what he did
say i said it's just bar talk and rumor
and third this stuff sounds like kind of
hyperbolic nonsense to me
i don't want anything to do with it the
source totally walks away from it
they have nothing been zero they don't
have one verified fact other than carter
page traveled to moscow
nothing i mean you know how evidence
works there is a probable a probable
cause standard
it's not nine out of ten if probable
cause is a ten
and reasonable suspicion is a five you
need ten to get a warrant you need
probable cause
you can't say oh i have nine point six
you understand they had zero
they had nothing carter page's trip to
moscow is evidence
of nothing it's not i've been to moscow
i've
it twice it's not i mean my producer did
he adopted his son from moscow is he
under investigation
they know no later than january of 2017
the case is a total fraud
but just to make things worse i think
don jr
having a decent relationship with him
now we'd say listen all right that
meeting was a bad idea
probably shouldn't have done it i don't
think anybody's going to say oh hey
great idea right
but here's the catch about even the
detroit the infamous trump tower meeting
with don jr
the emails were bad but he released them
which we can't say for hillary
i don't want to play what about ism but
he released them obviously had nothing
to hide he said here look at them
might have been a bad idea but here's my
email transactions about that meeting
and what's fascinating is they
interviewed the translator at the
meeting
this guy uh summit shornoff summit
surenov has no dog in this fight at all
he's a translator matter of fact he
tells the fbi during the interview
i don't even like don jr i can't stand
the guy but he says
everything he said about that meeting is
factually correct
this is just months after uh a month
after the january meeting with denchenko
so they know absolutely no later than
january february march of 2017
the whole thing's fake and they renew
the fisa three more times anyway
it what are their motivations they're a
lot i mean that was the original
question not to go on too long but
comey i think is just trying to keep his
job as fbi director
comey's shown himself to be again the
mercenary in the deal he's almost no
different
than manafort who damaged the trump
campaign by joining with all this
baggage
comey damaged the entire fbi by taking
the director's spot with all his
ego maniacal almost sociopathic baggage
but brennan's motivations are different
um not to get off on a tangent with mike
flynn but flynn's a part of this whole
process as well and
flynn had been almost a sworn enemy of
the swampy part of the intelligence
community for years
even stanley mcchrystal had praised him
saying hey this guy's a great intel
officer
but in his intel work he had attacked
some of the battlefield intel when flynn
was a three-star general saying hey
you're getting our guys killed you're
not going in these communities and
talking you're doing all this stuff from
you know a base in arlington they hated
him for it so flynn was public enemy
number one
so when you ask about the motivations
for brennan and others
i believe it was to make sure that mike
flynn
was never to take a position of
authority in the trump administration
because the dirty laundry
was definitely going to start to stink
really bad when he brought it out
so how high up did this go i mean the
the contention on
behalf of the obama administration is
that this was
relegated to comey and the intelligence
portions of the government
that biden and obama really were not in
on it that if they were that it was
really more tangential
in nature you've heard sort of a split
story uh from sally yates who is the
acting deputy attorney general at the
time
she said she was sort of surprised that
obamacare was in on it and kind of knew
about it so how high did this go
this went to the top i have no doubt
matter of fact john brennan right now is
starting to panic
brennan's being interviewed by durham
and a lot of people missed it but i
actually covered it on my show today
he writes an op-ed just a few days ago i
think it was august 30th or so
he writes an op-ed in the washington
post john brennan and halfway down
through the op-ed
he drops a bombshell that you know
unsurprisingly was ignored by everyone
in the media
that he briefed obama on the russia
information remember the whole thing's a
hoax the russia thing is a hoax
there is no russia information i need
everyone to understand there is not a
scintilla
of of evidence that the russians wanted
to help donald trump
none it's all made up that they
interfere in our elections a fact they
always do that
to help trump is made up he drops this
bombshell in the washington post opera
where he says oh i briefed obama on it
july uh
july 28th really essentially as days
before it was even opened at the fbi
nobody picked this story up now that's
fascinating and i think he's doing it
because brennan knows he's finished
right now
brennan knows he's the source of a lot
of these leaks or believed to be
these felony leaks so brennan could be
in a lot of legal trouble if he is in
fact
found to be the source he's taken the
whole place down with him he's not going
down alone
and i think this is the first crack in
the dam but to answer your question
about how high it goes i have
zero doubt zero that it goes right to
the top at obama
and obviously we have now the july 28
briefing before the fbi even opens the
case
that's brennan's words not mine so we
know that happened there's no reason for
him to lie about that
we have these infamous texts where
stroke and page
while they're in the context of a larger
communication about this whole scandal
they say uh the white house is running
this now
the leftist panicked over that tweet i
text excuse me and they said oh no no
they're talking about a china thing
that's totally ridiculous look at the
it's nonsense look at the context
there's another one another text i
believe it's in november
the potus of course in akron president
united states obama at the time the
potus wants to know everything we're
doing
again what are they talking about
talking about you know lego myego
they're talking about spygate potus
wants to know everything we're doing
but there's another one it gets even
worse so now you have three data points
right
that the white house was thoroughly
involved in this there's an even worse
email between
andy mccabe and lisa page it's right
around that november time block there to
october november and mccabe the deputy
director of the fbi and his lawyer there
um uh lisa page his lead lawyer
they're emailing each other about a
presentation about the case
they're gonna do with the white house
and they're talking about the cia and
the number two a guy named cohen
and they say in the email hey we really
need to go in there and have our like
one voice
in other words like the president must
have been asking questions about what
the cia and the fbi were doing and
they're confused
so and and they're not you know you have
another one the obvious susan rice email
you know the buy the book which
always remember you ever seen that movie
gi jane that's one of the worst movies
ever done yeah don't don't waste your
time but there is one good line in it
you know demi moore's trying to be a
navy seal and she walks in and she wants
to make a statement
and she says i don't want to make a
statement but so the guy comes back and
says people who don't want to make
statements
don't make statements about not making
statements so that's what that email was
like
people who want to make it let's say hey
let's do everything by the book you just
do it by the book you don't write an
email on the last day like right as
you're about right
i'll buy the book oh by the book and you
know the cc myself just to make sure i
have this for the record so
yes obama was intimately involved that
is going to be the biggest part of the
scandal he knew
i believe he marshalled it in
conjunction with brennan and i believe
comey was just really too dumb
to figure it out i mean this whole thing
obviously is an incredibly large scandal
i mean the idea of an
outgoing administration spying on the
candidate of the opposite party if
you're talking about george w bush doing
this in 2008 to barack obama
it's a world-breaking scandal it
happened to donald trump so of course
the media have
completely downplayed it or suggested
that it was not really a big deal it was
all done
in good faith so do you think that the
american people
are care about this do you think there's
an election issue because
obviously trump hasn't taken it on too
much and it may be too complicated for
people
to follow the media obviously have very
little interest in in laying it out
you know what i want what i think are
two different things i would hope the
american people largely would care
um it is only the biggest political
scandal of our time and it's not that i
don't have credibility on this either i
mean when i ran for office myself i ran
against the patriot act which was signed
by george w bush
i thought it was a bad idea i thought
the roving wiretaps were a bad idea
i thought these uh i thought maybe
outside of the lone wolf provisions
the business records provision was a bad
idea i didn't care that george w bush
signed that i'm actually concerned with
you know
little things like liberty and freedom
that seem to have gone by the wayside
um so i did have credibility on this but
i read an interesting tweet before i
came over this morning i was on the
plane flying out here
and there's a woman on the ground she
writes for a leftist outlet but she's on
the ground in wisconsin and she tweeted
out this thread
and the gist of it which was you know
really interesting she said i've spoken
to every single person i can for the
last four days in kenosha numbering in
the hundreds
she goes all you dc bubble dwellers
talking about your politics
she said these people give negative s
words about it they don't care they care
about their own
legitimate kitchen table stuff in their
kitchen
which is even odd because when we talk
about kitchen table issues you and i are
talking about different stuff
they're talking about their actual
kitchen like what matters to them on the
ground in their neighborhood
and she said i'm warning you you guys
are setting yourselves up for another
trump win here
because you're totally out of touch and
that's why to answer your question
i don't really think the spy gate story
resonates because for some
especially people like me who find it
interesting because my law enforcement
background the wonkery of it
is overwhelming you know you start
talking about fisa
how it works the jurisdictions overseas
the
gchq and the brits being involved and
people even my wife who nobody knows it
better than her she produces my show
with me
sometimes i'll do a segment on the show
and she's like my head's spinning right
now
it's complex and that's why when you
asked me in the beginning i tried to
boil it down to
a very simple thing the president united
states and a candidate was spied on
i really hope it aggravates people sadly
i'm not optimistic though it'll motivate
anyone to vote for anything i think
you're locked in on either side now so
looking at the election
how do you ballpark that so i've been
you know following it
the same way you have been and i i
always thought from the outset that the
trump was a bit of an underdog for
reelection simply because george w bush
lost the popular vote by 500 000 in 2000
and then he had to win an additional 10
million votes in order to win in 2004 in
a fairly close election with john kerry
trump lost the popular vote by 2.5
million and he would have to pick up
presumably somewhere between 12 and 14
million new votes
in order to make up that lost ground uh
that he
has you know he obviously broke hillary
clinton's blue wall but it was a i mean
really a
through the needle thing the eye of the
needle sort of thing 80 000 combined
votes in three states
and uh and the map has expanded pretty
wildly for democrats given 2018.
and so i always thought that he was a
bit of an underdog i thought that you
know maybe
before the before the cove pandemic i
thought that it was basically 50 50.
after the coveted pandemic i thought it
was about 65 35 for biden i'm now
thinking it's more like 55 45
for biden given the violence in the
streets and the fact that joe biden may
not be alive
well how do you ballpark the election
interesting um i would have told you two
three months ago
i would have gone even where i would
have said 70 30 biden because i thought
it was just
overwhelming i mean this no one had been
forced to deal with this just
meeting of of just almost apocalyptic
type events
at the same time this massive recession
we've never i mean who talking about 20
gdp drops that you would have laughed at
a number like come on stop that's
ridiculous it's never going to happen in
our lifetime
but now i'd say i'd say almost 55 45
trump and i'll give you the pros and the
cons
like you i'm a numbers guy right so
three million obama voters didn't show
up in the last 2016 election they'll be
here now i mean i think that's obvious
they're not voting for biden they're
voting against trump and anyone who
tells you anger is not a motivator is
is the only motivation it's the only
it's totally full of crap like has never
run for office
you know i've run three times sadly
unsuccessfully but um
you know that's total nonsense when you
knock on doors and talk to people
they'll vote just because they hate
another guy
so those three million obama voters will
be there and obviously we lost the
popular vote you know pretty handily
so that's kind of the downside to it the
upside
some anecdotal some statistical if the
democrats
lose a significant swath of the black
vote so president trump got eight
percent of the black vote
if he scores 12 i mean let's get out of
the area of ridiculous i've heard people
he's going to get 40
you're not going to get 40 okay stop
please stop the insanity like susie
powder
he doesn't need to get 40 number one but
if he gets say
12 to 15 which is in the realm of the
possibility
i i'd say at the high end 15
the democrat there's no mathematical
path to them in states like pennsylvania
with philadelphia
michigan with detroit there's no i mean
even maryland he's not going to win
maryland but maryland could even be a
five or six point race
so that's the uh the pro another
approach which is anecdotal granted and
you know
anecdotes anyone can find an anecdote
but ben people in my own family circle
who
shall remain nameless um who listen to
your show but they don't listen to mine
listen to your show
right they're like oh you have a show
i'm like you're in my family shapiro
what are you doing you gotta listen to
my show too but people in my family you
may have convinced them
and you're not even really like what we
consider like a pro like real maga guy
they love you
they're voting for trump because they've
seen the power of ideas when expressed
like you can they've come out die hard
die hard but i thought to be liberals
and my father's like nah she's voting
for trump i'm like what
are you crazy like that's not even my
brother he doesn't care if i'm in a
union electrician in new york never
voted for a republican
it's like heresy you could be branded
with the you could be a hester prin
you get the scarlet letter on you for it
my brother called me before the last
election
and he's like i'm voting for trump i
said you're doing what i was astonished
because i was still on board for cruz
he's like the union loves this guy he's
like i got to tell you dan about 85
percent of them love trump
these are constituencies and this is why
i think the polling candidly i think you
can scrap it
i almost think it's a useless data point
at this point because
when you look at that constituencies
they've had a really tough time
measuring in the past with republican
support
and you marry it up with the fact that
we've never had such
white working-class support in our lives
we've always had you know white
college-educated folks as well
so you get an increased minority vote
you get union voters you get police
officers in droves
probably going to win the military vote
combine that with white working-class
voters
that we've in numbers we've never seen
before and right now i think if the
economy holds i think it's 55-45
trump but you know i i predicted the
last the last win
yeah but i i certainly didn't i lost
money on the last election
you know what i figured i figured if
it's going to be a bad election for
republicans i might as well make a
little bit of money
for republicans uh crtv or the blade dan
harwich
yeah dan's a good guy so dan and i on
election night were there dan and i like
almost we were screaming at his
channel's like he's going to lose we're
going to lose 48 states this is going to
be a mess i said dan i had run in that
cycle i lost the primary
i said dan i knocked on doors in florida
i predicted
every state on my podcast the night
before it's still on soundcloud because
i knew it
quick one more quick ad because this is
another one's anecdotal stories this is
how i knew he was going to win
i'm knocking on doors in florida
district 19. you get a walk list of
republican voters for a primary
so i got this walk list and i'm calling
up my campaign manager because i'm
walking around cape coral with all these
canals
so you have to keep getting back in your
car you don't want to skip a house or
else you got to get into your car was
just a pain in the butt
i'd see a trump sign not on the list so
i call marie i go
why are you wasting my time you're
missing only what kind of data do you
have this crap
you're making me walk past all these
trump houses she goes damn they don't
vote
she said my date is good they don't vote
she goes do a test go knock on the doors
so i did trump signs you know what she
was right
probably four out of ten of them had
never registered to vote in their lives
but they were like i'm voting now and i
said to a maria this guy's going to win
florida they called florida like that
polls were done at nine in the panhandle
race was over so
in a second i want to ask you about how
you think the election is going to shake
out just in terms of the logistics of it
because that obviously has become a
major mess
first let's talk about something
important you should do for yourself and
your family i'm talking about getting
life insurance if you're a responsible
human being
you should have life insurance with
everything going on right now a lot of
people aren't even aware if it's
possible to buy life insurance at all
there is
good news it is still easy to shop for
life insurance right now and if you have
loved ones depending on your income you
definitely should
right now you could save 1500 bucks or
more a year by using policy genius
to compare life insurance policies when
you're shopping for a policy that could
last for a decade or more those savings
really start to add up so what exactly
is policy genius well
it's an insurance marketplace built and
backed by a team of industry experts
here's how it works step one
you go to policygenius.com in minutes
you can work out how much coverage you
need
and compare quotes from top insurers to
find your best price step two
apply for your lowest price step three
the policy genius team handles all the
paperwork
and the red tape and policy genius works
for you not the insurance company so if
you hit any speed bumps during the
application process
they'll take care of everything for you
they even have policies that allow
eligible customers to skip the in-person
medical exam and do it over the phone
which is
excellent at this point in time that
kind of service has earned policy genius
a five-star rating
across over 1600 reviews on trustpilot
and google
so if you need life insurance head on
over to policygenius.com right now to
get started you could say 1500 bucks or
more a year by comparing quotes on their
marketplace
policy genius when it comes to insurance
it's nice and important to get it right
okay so let's talk about how the
election shakes out i tend to agree with
you the reason i put it at 55 45 biden
is just because there's so many states
that are up for play
that there would have to be a massive
statistical error in order for trump to
really be up in all these states where
the polls say he's down but that could
happen and this is why i've ballparked
it this way
because i agree with you i think that he
he has not performed well in the suburbs
in 2018.
he's lost a lot of urban areas but there
could be massive rural turnout
particularly among first-time voters and
this was actually the obama model in
he didn't win as many votes as he did in
2008 and he won again but the reason he
did is because he got first-time black
voters to show up at the polls
and they had not been pulled and so a
lot of the polls were wrong and you
could certainly see the same thing from
trump you could see voters in places
like
kenosha who simply have not voted in the
past who are now motivated to go out and
vote because of everything that is going
on
one of the things that the democrats are
doing and the media are doing is this
sort of tacit threat thing where if
trump wins they're basically suggesting
that the world will burn down and then
as part of that tested threat they're
actually
effectuating that threat in major cities
across the country right now because
trump is president we're going to go in
riot and joe biden has
explicitly said that if he's president
there won't be any more riots which is
a fairly obvious blackmail tactic given
the fact that we may not actually know
who won the night of the election i mean
it may be that we get the immediate
results from the tabulated
voting places but the mail-in ballots
may take a week to count
and what do you think are the prospects
of serious conflict after this election
i'm terrified you know i've said on my
show
repeatedly and i'll continue to say
you know once you i used to host a radio
show in dc as a sub once in a while and
um
i'll never forget this call i was in on
the weekend guy calls in and
i'm just really upset at the whole
process he told me he was a conservative
but he's like
listen he said something to the effect
of you know i'm ready to go get my gun
and you know you're on in the open air
and you're like oh gosh
so instead of just immediately hanging
up and trying to kind of defuse this
situation on the air like
i said to him i said you know do you
know who your local
state rep is and he said no
and i said you know who your congressman
is and uh he said no
um i said you know i had to rub it in
but you know who your state senator is
he said no i said so just to be clear
you're ready to go get your gun but you
don't even know who
like it didn't and i wasn't trying to be
condescending i was trying to tell the
audience like number one this is
obviously illogical
insane stuff but secondly it's like
there are
a plethora of options to effectively
move the country in the right direction
like that obviously was the last one
available to us in the revolution there
was no other place to go
we're not even like close to that we
live in the wealthiest
most prosperous country not on earth in
the history of earth
since sentient beings and matter of fact
unless we find life anywhere else
in the entire cosmos the best place to
live
is here folks i get it i like the
president right
i don't mind his bravado i'm from queens
i know it bothers people
it doesn't bother me one bit it's
exactly me and my wife both
are from queens everyone was like that i
don't i get it some other people don't
like it
this is not the end of the world but i
am terrified that whereas i think
conservatives
see you and i have an emergency break
and the emergency break is our
ideological leanings and our faith
our emergency break as conservatives are
our political opponents
have god-given big our rights even
though we disagree with them
i have no right to assault them i have i
have a right to argue with them
but i have no right to hurt them to
wound them to damage them to bankrupt
them maliciously i don't have a right to
do that one it's morally wrong
and secondly we believe in a bill of
rights we believe that everybody has
those big our god-given rights
what worries me about the radical left
not all democrats a lot of democrats
tired of this nonsense too or else biden
wouldn't be coming out against it
the radical left there's no question
there's no emergency break whatsoever
that's what terrifies me about after the
election if you saw what me and my wife
saw leaving the acceptance speech at the
white house
ben i'm telling i know you've been
subjected to harassment i've seen it you
know people coming you know
everybody's a tough guy by the way you
know which is kind of hilarious um
you know you know everybody's with 30
people around but we walked out of the
acceptance speech at the white house
into i don't even know how to describe
it savages
animals people i mean legitimately like
foaming at the mouth spitting on you
calling my wife
a prostitute but not in such nice terms
believe me and
that's being nice uh what else did they
think
a a b a it was kind of like when you did
that hilarious segment about that that
song
wap and you had a wii u ppw exactly i
can't even say that
it's a family-friendly show give me a
letter and i'll tell you the word they
put behind it
i mean this went on for two miles they
followed us to the hotel i'm gonna kick
your ass i'm gonna
i'm gonna find you at the hotel in the
morning if it wasn't for
the five or ten or so border patrol guys
that saw me
and we're staying at the same hotel they
said dan walk with us
i don't i honest to god i don't know
what would happen that's why when rand
paul said they would have killed me and
everybody laughed at him i believe me i
wasn't laughing
i saw it these people were lunatics
i've never seen anything like it and i
can i mean
i mean obviously it's a dopey question
but can you ever imagine losing an
election to obama
showing up at his nomination speech at
the white house ben and
foaming at the mouth calling an 80 year
old man's wife a prostitute telling him
you're going to kick his
i mean what kind of a lunatic does that
and it's precisely because conservatives
have the emergency break
and liberals don't i'm very sorry again
it's not all democrats i'm not putting
i don't stereotype people the ones i've
run into these maniacs have no
emergency break whatsoever it's
frightening so let's talk about the
breakdown of law and order because
obviously that's become a key component
of the trump campaign
uh it's really shifted the nature of the
campaign to the point where it seems
like biden is very much on the defensive
as we record this
biden has been forced to exit the
basement and go to swing states which
suggests that he's got some internal
polling that differs pretty widely from
the public polling
and um he's he's taken the sort of
halfway position
between lawlessness and law and order
where he says
well you know the vast majority police
officers are good people but
the system is systemically racist now
you were a police officer
yeah what do you make of the argument
that the police are systemically racist
well like you i believe in the english
language
and and the power of words that mean
something
i don't know what that means i'm not
trying to be an idiot i'm not being
stupid or silly or coy
so systemically racist meaning there's a
system
that has a systemic problem that's
racist
so what's interesting is these
allegations of systemic racism
are only emerging from cities run by
systems that are dominated
monopolistically
by by liberals so i i don't get one what
system you're talking about then they
say oh no no
it's when they when they start talking
about amorphous blobs you know they have
no point
like seoul's great at dismantling these
arguments thomas soul he's a legend at
it
where he tries to pinpoint people down
to actual specific ideas that are
refutable
you know the whole essence of science
facts and data are ideas that are
refutable if you have an idea that's not
refutable
that's maybe faith that's but it's
certainly not science or data
nobody can tell you what the system
that's racist
is when you point to it they're confused
like i say in new york it's a majority
minority police department
now again it would be absurd to suggest
there aren't isolated examples of police
misconduct
brutality in some cases you know we've
had abs you know abject criminality
there's no question but we have systems
set up for that we have
civilian complaint review boards
obviously the criminal process
administrative procedures did you notice
they never
suggest any kind of legitimate fix it's
always
dismantle the police defund the police
they're systemically racist
it's never it's never real and and i
think where the biden campaign made a
huge mistake here
is obviously you know the sister soldier
moment that saved bill clinton's
campaign where he
sister soldier had this very
controversial song he came out and said
listen
it was wrong you can't talk like that
this is bad and of course the left wing
went nuts and bill clinton wound up
handily winning an election and
smoking it in the next election i'm not
defending bill clinton i'm just saying
like
it was biden's moment to come out and
say listen this has to stop
today period this is i am unequivocal in
this our police are generally very good
people policing cities for very little
money
we have these examples of misconduct but
the second part of law and order is
order
and order the essence of order is
processed and we have a process
if you have suggestions for fixing the
process i'm your president and i'm
willing to listen
we can repair and fix those processes
and everybody would have been on board
nobody sat there and defended what
happened to this guy in minnesota nobody
i was one of the first people on tv like
no no no no but we had a process the guy
got arrested he'll be tried
that's how this works biden didn't do
that he passed
and he made the same mistake david
dinkins did in new york i'll leave this
point with this because i lived through
this in new york city
new york city it was at that point three
to one democrat to republican you were
never going to get another republican
mayor again or so we thought
the city descended ben into total
madness madness
thousands of homicides a year i mean my
wife and i tell horror stories
your car it wasn't even a matter of
getting broken into it was only a matter
of how many times
i used to joke about they had that
device the club the steering wheel lock
and then the criminals learned how to
take the club off they would ice it with
freon spray
so then they had the club cover where
you put so they couldn't cut the
steering wheel and then they told people
no no put the club cover on backwards so
they can't hammer the club that's how
bad the problem was they had a like
a multi-layered club so they wouldn't
steal your car it was such an
embarrassment
like it was like when am i going to get
mugged not is it going to happen
giuliani comes in runs on a strict law
and order message i mean that's
basically i'm going to cut taxes law
order that's his entire message
he wasn't a very socially conservative
guy at the people forget that
he comes in i've lived through this
entire thing he slides by loses the
first time
wins the second time slides by runs for
re-election everybody's like this guy's
got no
shot the city's almost entirely cleaned
up disney moves into times square he
wins by 18 points
in new york city how biden didn't see
this coming
i mean it was the biggest you know
warning sign
exclamation point in the middle of it
i've ever seen and he blew it he's never
had that moment
and and he won't and i think this is
going to be his downfall i mean i'm
i'm shocked that the trump campaign has
not as of yet really gone
even more aggressive on on this
particular point i mean joe biden went
and visited kenosha
and uh and while visiting kenosha he
made a phone call to jacob blake the man
who was shot by the kenosha police
jacob blake is an alleged rapist the
reason that the police were there is
because
they were called to the scene by a woman
who alleged that he digitally raped her
with her child in the room
and there was joe biden suggesting that
the officers who had to shoot him
because he was
resisting arrest and went around to the
driver's side of his car and tried to
pick a
knife up off the floorboards that they
shot him and
biden's response was to call jacob blake
with condolences an alleged rapist
and to suggest that the officers be
arrested
i i don't know how that has not become
the focal point of of the trump campaign
at this point frankly
yeah you know i was doing an appearance
and i mentioned this the other day that
isn't it so bizarre that the social
fabric has just
collapsed to such a point where remember
when we were kids you played cops and
robbers and
no nobody wanted to be the robber like
that was like the kid you didn't like
the neighbor make him the robber
we don't like him you know poor guy yeah
boy i don't want to be the robbery
now it's the opposite everybody wants to
be the robber and not the cop and you
think
the damage they've done to our culture
where
they've unmoored us from any objective
values of what's good
you know i read this this great piece in
the journal forgive me i can't remember
it was an op-ed about a week ago
it was on the weekend i can't remember
the author which i hate uh because
it should give him a hat tip but it was
such a wonderful piece how
when you accept this idea that oh all
ideas have equal validity then none do
um because it's absurd like there's
there's there's
unquestionably top of the totem pole bad
ideas that should be absolutely
categorically
disregarded like the police are
generally good law and orders a good
thing
rioting is bad but now we see this new
book like in defense of looting
i mean this is what happens and this is
how you get a society where
people want to be the robber now and not
the cop which ironically that book
one of my friends put out a tweet the
other day which was hilarious the in
defense of looting book where again all
ideas are worth hearing uh which you and
i both know are not like socialism is
not worth hearing out
um whoever tells you that's a with
no context for history at all
the in defense of looting book if you go
to the flat back of the front flap
um it has a copyright thing where you
need permission of to
print this book so don't loot that book
which is right don't loot my book just
loot everybody else's book
and this is the left they've unmoored us
from any sense of objective good
and when you think about it you know the
reason why they do that is quite simple
i mean the whole essence of socialism
is a is a subjective interpretation of
at any given moment what's good or bad
for the collective
if you have a set of bedrock ideas and
big our constitutional rights
socialism can't exist because the
essence of it is to treat people
unequally right
these are the bad guys these are the
good guys the next day no no those are
the bad guys these are the good guys
take
their these are the farmers the dread
though they were good guys yesterday
none of the bad guys today steal their
stuff
that's what socialism is it requires
subjectivity and the left is
the left really through their academic
institutions has dismantled any sense
right now of objective good
to the point where a guy running for
president meets with the guy accused of
this disgusting crime
and and nobody i mean ben really is is
it even a scandal no
nobody's even talking about it which i
want to talk to you about in one second
i want to ask you
about the the media coverage of this
race because it is the media coverage
for the last few years they have
clowned themselves in such grandiose
fashion i've never seen anything
remotely like it we'll get to that in
one second but first
let's talk about the fact that out in
the garage you've got a bunch of old
memories they are trapped and degrading
we're talking about old camcorder tapes
you can't use them you're talking about
old film reels you can't use them
pictures that are falling apart
you need to get this stuff fixed up asap
you need to get it transferred over to a
nice digital format so it's usable and
movable
legacy box can do all of this for you
legacy box is a super simple mail-in
service to have all your videotapes
camcorder tapes film reels pictures
digitally preserved on a thumb drive at
dvd or the cloud
with summertime officially coming to an
end everybody's got fall on the brain
what were your favorite fall childhood
memories apple picking carving pumpkins
football games watching the leaves
change
being able to preserve those memories
that's what legacy box was created
to do let them digitally preserve your
past and bring new life to those trapped
family memories
i've been using legacy box myself with
my parents they got a bunch of old boxes
old film reels it's getting all
transferred over to a digital format so
we can actually
look at it again for the first time in
probably four decades legacy box is a
way for you to easily and affordably
digitally preserve your past
the process from start to finish is
really easy you pack you send their team
digitizes
everything by hand and you enjoy get
started preserving your pass today with
our labor day sale go to legacybox.com
shapiro to get 50 off your first order
order today
send it in when you're ready this
exclusive offer is not going to last for
long go to legacybox.com
shapiro say 50 while supplies last so
let's talk about the media coverage of
all of this stuff so
obviously you've created a very large
media persona for
yourself uh you've even created a sort
of response to the drudge report called
the bonjino report
and you were one of the first people to
publicly say what everybody sort of knew
which is that matt drudge is off the
train so matt drudge was a driving force
behind
donald trump's primary victory he really
covered him in extraordinarily positive
fashion during the primaries in 2016
and throughout the election cycle he was
pretty positive toward toward trump in
2016.
and then sometime in 2017 2018 it seems
like the coverage of drudge report has
basically
mirrored that of the new york times to
the point where nearly every headline
looks like it's almost originating from
biden hq at this point
you've called that out publicly what
what do you think has happened with
regard to
places like drudge you know i don't know
with drudge specifically
um there's rumors obviously he sold the
site i can't confirm i hate even
saying but it's out there if you google
it um he's so reclusive nobody can ever
get a quote from so nobody really knows
what happened with drudge
people who've known him in the past who
worked with him
i've told me that he can be very kind of
mercenary himself that he just runs with
the headlines
i don't know um but i i didn't do it for
the money i mean i know that's like the
worst liner but it's true i really
didn't i just
didn't like drudge every i mean you woke
up everybody's like everybody's gonna
die from the corona
don't go out in public it's it's uh not
only is it airborne but it's ten
thousand times more infectious than any
disease on this and
i was like listen i want facts okay i
have to live my life in the real world
um and and you know i do show prep like
you do and i found the drug report to be
increasingly
useless it was just non-stop corona
hysteria
you know orange man bad trump is awful
you know finally we found the collusion
and i was like this is just a waste of
my time
so we we did bongino report and it took
off fat i mean it's just people we're
looking for
and there's a number of others that do
it too as well that do a really terrific
job
and i give them hat tips all the time
like i said it's really not about for me
the money the projects i choose to get
involved with i always get involved with
because i'm passionate about them you
know i do the same thing with social
media with some projects i'm involved in
there
but with the media you know it's
stunning like you and i if we get
one nugget of a fact wrong matter of
fact i'll put meat on a bun i'll give
you an
extra example i'm running for office in
florida and i had um
i said something during the debate that
education spending since i was born in
the 1970s
has gone up 400 percent and yet our
international results have flatlined so
obviously the correlation between money
and education results aren't there well
the next day was an article in the
naples daily news and
say no that's not true it's when you
adjust it for inflation it's not 400
it's like 372.6 he's definitely lying
and i i mean i looked and i remember i
get in a big fight with you and then i'm
like why am i even bothering
this is clownish but that's the the
environment you and i live in we have to
be perfect all the time
or else we're conspiracy theorists and
we're never to be the tin foil hats come
on ben shapiro oh my god
he look at this guy he dared to say that
there was
2 million in federal spending and it was
2.6 he doesn't know what he's talking
about
but what's totally bizarre about this is
you can get the two biggest scandals of
our time
wrong in the media you can say spygate
was a hoax it wasn't
and collusion was real it wasn't
and you get a pulitzer prize nobody
ben no career damage at all maggie
haberman
adam goldman natasha bertrand david corn
i mean the list goes on and on of people
who have never apologized not
one moment for this scandal have
promoted the two biggest hoaxes of our
time
and they got pulitzer prizes for this
thing meanwhile you and i you get a
decimal point wrong and we're finished
so you know the only good news to that
because that sounds very macabre is you
know you look at polls
and you see who are the trusted sources
of information and it's guys like you
me and fox news and nobody trusts them
so the answer is who's really winning
and it's us i mean we have
enormous audiences we're like me and i
are like the the wonder twins
i mean you're always one i've never ever
beat you ever your show is amazing
people love
people show up at book signings for me
they don't even they don't even know i
have a show
they see me from fox and i say oh you
listen to pogba yeah listen shapiro
get out of my books you gotta listen so
who's really winning
people are seeking out information where
they know they're not gonna be lied to
wait one more because this is funny too
because like rachel maddow i love this
topic how do you watch this show for
three years knowing this woman's been
lying to you
or if not lying is so incompetent that
she promoted a hoax the collusion hoax
and you don't wake up one morning and go
wow
i spent an hour every night at nine
o'clock on a show eastern time
that was just total bs like that doesn't
bother you
i mean there was one i forget what we
said there was one thing one story we
had to come back the next day
we screwed it up i get out ahead of it
oh i said that christine blasey ford was
not going to show up
i was sure of it i was no way i knew
that i was very suspect about the story
when the cavanaugh hearings of course
and i said to my audience there's no way
she's showing up i'll bet my right arm
on it
you know she of course she showed up and
for the next week i apologize profusely
every day to my audience
and for days they're like all right
enough like you made your point you
apologize move on
but i felt like i'd legitimately let
them down and made a point every day to
almost go over the top and say i let you
down
bad call i predicted it wrong not the
spygate
hoaxers and the collusion hoaxers
nothing one of the things that's truly
amazing is that it's pretty obvious that
social media
has allowed avenues for you know people
like you people like me to get our
message out there and when those
messages become popular
the old media immediately jump in to
attempt to control social media so
you've seen this mostly from people like
kevin roose at the new york times
who every single day he hates me oh yeah
tomorrow
every single day every single day he
posts the facebook statistics showing
that your page is popular then my page
is very popular
and then he the implication of course
being that facebook is putting out this
information it never seems to occur to
him that maybe the reason people like
our information
is because the new york times won't
report the kind of stuff that we talk
about on a daily basis and instead
denies entirely these narratives and
this is i think the blind spot for the
media and it's the reason they've lost
so much credibility
and now they're stuck i think they've
moved themselves into a box canyon where
they can't get out because if they
acknowledge
that the narratives that you and i
pursue on a daily basis and talk about
because we'll talk about all the same
stuff they're talking about
but we will also talk about these other
narratives that they won't talk about
right i mean
we you talked about spygate you talked
about the russia hoax and and all of
that
for years on your program i talked about
it and i was actually more friendly
toward i tried to you know give your
point of view but also talked about you
know that what the new york times was
saying on a daily basis
and that still wasn't good enough for
them but then we would talk about other
narratives that were in the news that
get completely ignored
and instead of the new york times
starting to cover some of those other
narratives or you know hire a
conservative journalist or hire somebody
their op-ed page who might disagree with
somebody once in a while
instead of doing that they've decided
that they actually want to hijack the
social media networks and try to
pressure them
into shutting off access to information
that conservatives
provide and that's that's a truly
amazing thing and so now they basically
just have to double down on on what they
have because if they ever acknowledge
that maybe we're providing information
that is useful then they have to
acknowledge they've been doing it wrong
all these years
and simultaneously if they acknowledge
that we're successful because people
want that information
then they have to acknowledge that
social media is not biased it's just
that
they're not performing their jobs
particularly well that's a huge story
and i'm so glad your audience is going
to get a get a kick at this because
there's no
two better people to talk about than me
and you you and i on any given day
there's a twitter account facebook's top
ten
and it monitors via crowdtangle the most
popular post
of the day there's not a day during the
week that either you or i aren't on that
you're usually you usually have three or
four posts and on a good day we'll have
three or four usually we have one
one or two so you and i have very
popular top 10 pages in the united
states for posts
and you just said it it bothers him so
much that a writer i believe for the new
york times guy roos who monitors the
facebook top and he only does it
to pressure facebook to say listen these
right-wing provocateurs
are posting content that we just don't
ideologically like matter of fact there
was an article in the week
about me and you this by this other
clown not roos but
suggesting somehow that this we're
promoting disinformation which is
incredible because again
facebook has an army of fact checkers
literally dedicated to destroying the
lives of conservatives and i hate
literally because it's literally the
most overused word in the english
language
but i literally mean that they have an
army of fact checkers deployed
that just target almost almost
exclusively conservative pages
if what we're saying is false because we
get it about once a month
um we'll get one of these fake fact
checks which is really an opinion piece
why aren't we getting it every day why
is our page still up and what bothers
them more
is that there's an interesting thing
about your page and my page that they
never tell the story
most of the posts on our you know we'll
put clips kaylee mac and amy donald
trump whatever you know everybody has a
few news eclipse
you know you put a little spicy headline
whatever but
50 60 70 of the material is material we
write like daily wire stuff you guys put
together
and my clips from my show so if what i'm
saying on my show is false then where
are your army of fact checkers calling
me out
so what they're saying is they're
bothered by the truth and it's really
stunning and and i don't think the
audience really gets
behind the scenes how much pressure you
guys get it more than i do because the
daily wire has its own
distinct from ben shapiro has its own
distinct i mean you guys are
you know you work for the wire and all
and with them but you guys have a
multiple different like layers of
success on facebook
your team is phenomenal just really good
at it
it drives them wild and the pressure to
get you and me
pulled off i mean i don't know how you
feel about it your show i'm not
interviewing you but
i i think the guy i work with on
facebook who helps me produce the
content
he's like just milk it as long as you
can because you won't be here long you
know i
i will say that you know i think that
not all these companies operate the same
way
i think that twitter is more of a threat
to conservatives just by statistics than
than facebook is i think that listen
i've said it before i think that
zuckerberg
seems to have an ideological commitment
to the idea at least
of of people being able to get their
opinion out there it may be imperfectly
applied by
his company but he at least is is
mouthing those words and i think he
actually does care about that stuff i
think that
the precise opposite applies to people
like jack dorsey uh who
brutally wants to shut down anybody who
disagrees with him uh i think there are
some others
like i think treating all social media
identically is silly and listen i'd be a
hypocrite if i say out here and i i
think we have the
i think my page may be the most
successful facebook page in the united
states would be
really hypocritical for me to talk about
being silenced on facebook um but you
can certainly see it on twitter i mean
on twitter for sure and it's and the
pressure
is exorbitant i mean there are people
who are out there every day trying to
get you demonetized
uh getting people like you're crowded
monetized on youtube youtube
they're people out there every single
day who are trying to pressure these
companies into
literally kicking off the pages who are
trying to get our advertisers to drop us
because the advertisers have to be
pressured and that's a serious thing
that the right
has not done and it's put me in the
position of basically saying
listen if you guys continue this at a
certain point we're going to have to
engage in mutually assured destruction i
don't want to do it like i think that
anybody should be able to advertise on
whatever program they damn well please
and if acura wants to advertise with
rachel maddow
enjoy but if it's going to come to the
point where nobody's allowed to
advertise on your show or advertise on
my show
if they buy an ad on the sunday special
then the left then the left is swarm
them
then there will come a point where the
right is just going to say listen we'll
do the exact same thing to your
advertisers
and then nobody will have advertising
revenue and then we'll see how you like
this
gosh i could talk to you about this
whole topic for hours but a couple
things are so much in there
on the advertising front without getting
too specific i think though we need to
stick together too guys like you
and me and crowder and people who are
into clave and knowles all of us we have
power
i mean on any given day on itunes it's
you me
michael andrew we have we're doing
audiences similar to cable news channels
no doubt about it we have power too
people want to sell products they have
to sell products to people well we have
the people we have the eyeballs and we
have the ears
but we've got to stick together and i
think in this business unfortunately
there's too much um you know dog eat dog
stuff which i get it it's a business
um but i i can candidly tell you i've
never viewed your show as a competitor
no i'm never we don't we don't that's
not how we think of the conservative
ecosystem no i i
yeah and i've never thought of it that
way i've always thought you know i've
promoted your work you've promoted yeah
i mean i had michael on my show and we
were laughing upstairs
he had a great weekend after that with
subs because i love his show
and i think there's there's space in
people's lives for between four to six
hours of content i mean hannity rush
and levin have dominated that's nine
hours of content for years
you know i only do an hour's show i
never viewed you guys as a competitor
but we do have to stick together with
the ad stuff there was an incident that
happened i'm not going to get into the
details obviously but
it had something to do with your show
and someone else and
i made sure to make a phone call and
without again getting into specifics
saying
no we're not doing that and they're in
the penalty box and they
what do you mean we're not doing it
that's
you'll i'll tell you later but yeah i
think you kind of know oh
and i let them know that that's not the
and believe me they were like well what
do you mean you sell a lot of our
widgets
not for the next few months we didn't
sell any yogurt exactly no i mean
we have to do that absolutely i mean
we've not again that's getting specifics
but we've
written into contracts that people are
not allowed to just willy-nilly be
pressured by
you know the leftist ecosystem into
pulling their advertising because
no i mean they're asking us to voice
their product which
we're very specific about we don't just
sell anything no listen they trust us to
talk about their product in an honest
way and we trust them not to undercut
ourselves i mean
this relationship does go both ways
right and not only that i mean i think
that the right needs to stick together
when any of us get boycotted right i
mean when people have
tucker when people go after sean when
people have to rush and that is a
routine thing
that's a routine thing is to try and
knock advertisers out and
you know to get there will come a point
where the right decides that they've had
enough of this and
the eventual answer is going to be
launching of right-wing companies in
exactly the same areas that don't
actually care anymore i mean you've seen
this with black rifle coffee one of our
sponsors right black rifle
looked at starbucks and they said okay
well if you guys are going to market to
the left then we're going to mark it to
the right we'll put a gun on our cover
and
people will buy our coffee and they do
an awful big business you know roger
ailes who whatever you think his
problems were or not um when i was an
instructor in the secret service academy
a guy who was graduating in the class
knew him
so he came down to give a speech this is
years ago gosh i don't know 2002
whatever it was
but he comes down he was taking
questions afterwards in front of a small
group of parents
proudly watching their kids graduate and
someone asked him you know how did you
come up with the idea of fox news and i
never forgot this
he said i was sitting there at my house
one day and i thought gosh there's this
underserved market in america
called 51 percent of america that like
it's
like he's joking i'd be like why isn't
there a conservative news station so
what you're saying about a whole
conservative ecosystem
of social media products advertising
companies
ad reps everything it's emerging now
we're seeing it now
on our end but that just kind of
doubling down on this
you're seeing it now though too even
companies like like youtube who've
decided it's a good idea to demonetize
anything i say and they don't demonetize
almost any leftist channels
we figured out ways around it you know
on youtube i read the ads in the show
you want to take my show off youtube
makes probably millions of dollars a
year off my show
i'll find another outlet i really at
this point i don't care i
i talk about youtube on my show all the
time you want to host my show fine we
can be business partners in this
you don't i will happily move on to
another outlet i'm really okay with that
i don't have any problem with youtube
i don't boycott youtube because they
host leftist shows i don't care
and like you said about the advertisers
i have never once once like mistakenly
watched cnn in an airport because that's
the only place you see it
and seeing an advertiser be like oh my
gosh i got to boycott this company
because again it goes back to that
conversation we had about you know law
order and big r god given rights
it's a company they're not advertising
cnn they're advertising their product to
cnn's audience
these whiner infants on the left
oh my gosh ben shapiro was talking about
abortion we can't talk about abortion
boycott this show
they're not nobody's endorsing anything
i don't even care what your views are
you're selling a product man
get over it and then one final not on
twitter i agree
i it would be hypocritical for me too to
bash facebook our page is you know doing
not as well as yours but
pretty darn good we do get fact checked
a lot we get a lot of stupid stuff
but twitter's a train wreck um you know
i don't i think jack's money maker has
always been
square i think twitter's his play thing
i don't think he cares
what you think um i don't i think he'd
kick you off tomorrow if he felt like it
and i think he'd flip your two middle
fingers and say have a nice day and
matter of fact i would not be stunned
again i'm not in the predictions game
i'm just saying i would not be shocked
at all
if there's some adverse action against
the president close to or after election
day who depending on who wins
i i wouldn't i wouldn't where he's just
suspended and
and then i think people are going to
start to really wake up that
you know you i would never get rid of my
twitter account i mean
full disclosure i have an ownership
stake in parlor so your audience is not
in any way confused i do it it's recent
but
i i did that because i say to people i
don't want you to cancel your twitter
there is a fight there to be had i just
wanted to make sure you have a home base
somewhere else
where you can go to twitter and play
with the liberals all you want but
understand that
your time is limited there and i believe
again on facebook i think my time is
limited too
i i wish it weren't the case i mean i
really there are billions of people
there that could use our information
and i i think my days are numbered there
so in a second i want to ask you about
your secret service service like what
was that like because i think people
have misperceptions of what exactly that
constitutes i want to ask that question
i want to i want to ask you that
question so we're going to talk about
what it was like to be in the secret
service because you actually were in the
secret service when obama was president
of the united states we'll get to that
in a second but first if you want to
hear dan bongino's answers you have to
be
a daily wire member so head on over to
dailywear.com click subscribe you can
hear the rest
of our conversation over there well dan
bunchito
check out his new book follow the money
the shocking deep state connections of
the anti-trump
cabal dan thanks so much for stopping by
really really appreciate it this was one
of the best interviews we've done
i feel really good so thanks great
talking buddy
the ben shapiro show sunday special is
produced by mathis glover
executive producer jeremy boring our
technical director is austin stevens
and our assistant director is pavel
wydowski associate producer nick sheehan
our guests are booked by caitlin maynard
editing is by jim nicholl
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by nika geneva title graphics
are by cynthia angulo the ben shapiro
show sunday special is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 20 20.